right now
you've heard this whole debate over
critical race theory a lot of the
reformers will say
no critical race theory it's not real
it's not it's just a
academic movement that's taught in a
handful of law schools it's not
affecting your kids
ignore it ignore it ignore it well
there's a report out now a virginia
public school district
sent a powerpoint to teachers explaining
how to explicitly implement
critical race theory in the classroom
this is the fairfax
county public school sent out the
resource as a teacher-facing item so
it's not meant to be seen by the kids
and not meant to be seen by the parents
and certainly not meant to be seen by
you or me as we're reporting it on this
show
but it's talking about critical race
theory how to include quote
culturally relevant pedagogy
institutional systemic racism
anti-racism education anti-hate
education
blah blah blah and the district rightly
defines critical race theory as a quote
interpretive framework that examines the
appearance of race and racism across
dominant
cultural modes of expression and in
adopting this approach
critical race theory scholars attempt to
understand how victims of systemic
racism are affected by cultural
perceptions of prejudice and all the
rest of it
so don lemon recently on cnn was trying
to peddle this
silly idea the critical race theory it's
not being taught in schools
no it's just some a couple people at
harvard law school but that's it it's
not being taught to your kids or
anything
and russ douthit from the new york times
the more conservative
writer at the new york times he smacked
that down
you're encouraging kids white kids to
have
sort of to to in effect cultivate a kind
of sense of their own whiteness with the
idea being that
if you encourage that these kids will
then
be able to sort of recognize their own
white privilege
and transcend it but that's a lot of
where the controversy is right it's
about
these programs that aren't teaching
about the history of racism aren't even
teaching about sort of
contemporary contemporary effects
they're specifically saying
you know white kids especially need to
think of themselves
in these categories and in these ways
and that's
i think a big part of what people are
reacting against yeah listen i
i don't know if that in fact is
happening but i mean russ we should say
that critical race theory is not being
taught
uh it's not part of the curriculum for
uh elementary or grade school students
it's something that's taught
in law schools just so we know but
that's not exactly right critical race
theory is an
incredibly influential set of ideas that
has ex
solid influence in education schools and
elsewhere
no but but ross i'm gonna just
completely ignore everything you've said
for the past 40 seconds and just
just beep boop critical race theory not
in schools beep beep boop
and then ross death who's very
thoughtful person says
what did you not just listen to no it
that's not right don
it obviously is ideas have consequences
and even ideas that begin in a law
school
will have an effect well certainly an
idea that begins in a law school is
going to have an effect on the broader
legal community and on the law and the
way that we govern ourselves in our
country and it's
going to have an effect on pedagogy down
the line as it has including in
elementary schools
before you accuse me take a look at
yourself that's the name of this
entire episode you liked the clip you
liked the episode
yeah we actually do talk about eric
clapton on that show because eric
clapton is taking a firm stand
against vaccine mandates head on over
right now to the michael knowles show on
youtube you can get it on apple podcast
spotify stitcher google play myspace
xanga livejournal and you can also get
my book speechless controlling words
controlling minds
see you next time
[Music]
you